Je vous ai demandé d'apporter le vert, vous
devez être notre visage sur la fusion,
bien sûr, je serais honoré monsieur
m.  Dale prend ta sœur Lily, je
ne peux pas parler en ce moment, je
leur écris,
je n'irai pas à
Winchester que j'ai apporté les
dépositions avec moi et je suis totalement
au courant, je peux travailler à partir d'ici d'accord, je
suppose quel  jeu cruel auquel tu joues avec
ton père maintenant tu n'as pas besoin de le
voir après tout
maman n'aurait pas dû venir je sais
que rien n'a changé hein
tu es de retour en ville pour rester juste ici pour
les funérailles papa était tout bon à
propos de cet endroit  tu as dit que tu ne
me quitterais jamais mec juste au moment où nous étions sur le point de
devenir sérieux j'avais besoin d'un changement de rythme
ray love si tard c'est là
qu'il nous voulait les gens qu'il aimait ensemble je
ne pense pas que maman et papa aient jamais été les
mêmes  après ton départ, je pense que tu lui as brisé
le cœur, il a toujours été le mien en premier quand tu
penses que tu as tout pensé que
tu pourrais vouloir regarder un peu en profondeur,
c'est magique à propos de cette lumière qui arrive,
il fait froid
.  Je vais
devoir être expulsé de rien je t'aime
Sarah j'v  Je t'ai toujours aimé Je ne rentre pas
à la maison sans
jamais voir ces Valley
car il t'aimait tellement